[Music]
this week in
feminism so then I came back from the
tattoo parlor and my boyfriend didn't
like my spacers or my nose piercing or
my bowl
cut no he teting so
else
[Music]
patriarchy remember none of this is
possible without you join the fight and
sign up for mug club today at
lwicc mugclub for $89 annually join the
fight at lorth cr.com mugclub
[Music]
[Applause]
today
[Music]
what I
know all right hey settle settle
something for us comment below when we
do the tip sheet at the top of the
show Captain Morgan here and Tool Man
were arguing about it do you you like
them as the lower thirds or as a full
screen Tip Sheet all right here we go
now I'm back to the old headphones so I
just have to keep I just have to keep
adjusting yeah all right you'll get
there so let me give you the rundown
we'll be discussing this today yesterday
obviously was all about you know um the
the Jews at war with Hamas okay but
today we're going to be discussing the
the westerners I should say the Western
terrorists yeah yeah they it's like
terrorists who shop at Cavenders
and they are celebrating Hamas and they
are blaming Israel and by the way that
includes a lot in the media so um I want
to discuss this in the root cause of
this I get it by the way not all Muslims
line up this way but there are too many
that do and we'll give you some numbers
that are shocking and of course some
quotes from Quran from Hadith so I would
warn you if you're in the vicinity of
terrorists you know and they have the
ability use a VPN we'll also be talking
about uh former Vice President Biden his
switch on the border because it's all
ties together I don't know if you know
this pretty easy for terrorists to walk
through that border he's an about face
and he's trying to claim credit for
Donald Trump's work RFK Jr is going to
be running as an independent and there
was a writer a journalist uh I believe
in Sweden who got 60 days for calling a
journalist a fat
lesbian that's yeah that's for M there
are things we're going to say that you
can't so let me ask you have you seen
any of the pro Palestine meaning Pro
Hamas protests near you in your city
comment below if they've been taking
place in your city they've been taking
place all across the United States and
Canada and it's a pretty terrifying uh
it's a pretty terrifying notion uh all
right we'll talk oh and and you know
what today since we're going to be
discussing this if at any point you see
this if you're watching on YouTube and
you see
this that's the YouTube dump button head
on over to rumble which is where you
should be watching anyway we're not
going to self- censor you know but I
have no idea how this plays out today
I'm going to be honest with you there's
a multitude of ways this goes and most
of them not well number two CEO Gerald
Morgan how are you sir I am doing well I
feel a year
older why it's my birthday yesterday oh
that's right you feel year old sorry I
was distracted because on CN right now H
mire is hundreds of rockets towards
ashalon ashalon Israel well but then
they show like the one boat that got hit
in the harbor it's like guys it looks
like you missed yeah you hit one some
poor Schmucks little trowler we hit the
scallop
fisherman they don't need scallops I
hate deadliest sketch
yes it show is unreasonable it is
unreasonable no shellfish it says people
of the book you lie what that's theology
because they call the Jews the people of
the book but they say the Jews lie about
everything they Muhammad said that the
Jews lied about everything which you
know it's like I don't know I have no
idea it's an evil ideology and when you
hear this you know who is in third chair
he brings a smile to our face you know
him you love him you can follow him on
the Instagram at Josh orire Stein Stein
so don't ask him all the Jew questions
today it's fire Stein yes and Friday
October 13th he'll be at Messi Jesse's
in abine Washington Josh you are quick W
that was just give him
a Josh thank you for your service how
are you today thank you I'm good I'm
good man by the way fire Stein like
Palestine yeah how you say way to do
that's how you say it thanks
Jackie canceling my Palestine I will be
talking about Palestine it is
clandestine what shut up J you're a
fullblown
swine okay black people like rhyming
they're good at it now the best the best
really are some might say they really
are we would never say it but someone
else might say it larly black people now
before we go into this because I know it
was Heavy yesterday uh this is not fun
but then we have a fun clip here's a
drag queen um this is heavy
too here is a drag queen receiving money
uh from a child even though of course
none of these drag queen shows take
place or inappropriate with
[Music]
children
[Applause]
what's the outfit is like pansexuals
[Music]
Labyrinth I think it's a male efficent
oh it is yeah that is what it
is by the way we have to blur out the
child's face uh because of the law but
apparently they can consent to male
efficent I like that yeah thank you I
thought it was I thought thought it was
the pan Labyrinth thing you know where
he would just be holding up fake ovaries
in the
eyes they have no creative Direction at
these drag shows where's the Sailor with
a bottle when you need him
now that was traumatizing in that in
that film boy it just comes outwhere and
then there was what is it the shape of
water just a lady getting busy with a
fish yep no I never saw that's a weird
one that's a weird one I thought I was
like maybe they fall in love but no it's
like there it's that Oscar there's a
montage of like do not disturb signs
going up in every room in the house and
you just her and fish crazy and they
have a
mermaid hey and it was a white one
too let's say I mean they have their
limits they're old school Trad we don't
Mi I'm fine of your inner species we do
not mix not with you're going to be with
a white bass that's a white fish no
black fish no mackerels either no
mackerels no that's stri I won't even go
striped bass okay I don't care
definitely none of them your white bass
that is what's happening drag queens
across the and by we have our
investigative journalists out there
right now finding some more we've had a
few of them shut down but here's a
here's a pleasant pallet cleanser um I
guess after the last few days here's uh
if you like uh large black women and you
like guns this clip is for you
[Music]
mhm are they in front they in front of
the cat and a hat
[Laughter]
[Music]
house
oh I like her point it down good Trigger
Discipline by the way after that they
robbed all those houses yeah that's true
guy came outside get off my
long I thought it looked like San
Francisco yeah it could be no Oakland
Oakland
aame hey good for them good for them and
you know what this is what we talk about
sing with Sanctuary cities you know
who's most negatively affected by
Sanctuary cities legal immigrants who
live there and have to live under the
rule of drug cartel proxies same thing
black women hey they're if they have to
live in areas where there is rampant
crime they're the people who should be
they should be most likely they they
should be granted the right of way the
express aisle right I even would allow
you know 12 guns or I would even allow
the grace gun 13 guns there you go to
get right out of Cabellas and go back to
the neighborhood and protect themselves
so good for themas or whatever it is
Bass Pro I don't whever wherever you buy
your firearm your local firearms dealer
try the Walter by the way okay anything
else you guys wanted to say about that
nice little plug there I want to say
Walters are great guns they really are
they're Fant yeah try it out go to the
range buy one protect your neighborhood
I don't know if they would love them
because Walters are very they're very um
they're not blingy they're very
effective but not blingy you don't hide
one you can hide one in your bra yeah
you could yeah exactly there's a lot
that you can hide in that bra yeah you
can I do wield a trebuchet yeah a
treuchet so before we go on better watch
Y come out you with my PR
buet this is my cousin hold on let me
set it
up boom boom Banger rang
yep that was back when you could have
fat kids as rolls and it was okay for
them to be fat they were like hey we
have a fat kid now should we make him a
should we make him a pride icon like no
let's fold up his legs and turn him into
a human
Cannonball how it works you ever go to
an audition and see a line for a kid
roll fat kid yeah exactly yeah me sucks
to be that guy yeah
exactly
I'll tell you the story of my first time
are You Afraid of the Dark where I was I
was just brought in as a token white guy
the name was Wang and it was the tale of
The Misfortune cookie and as I was
auditioning I was going call this the
tale of The Misfortune and it just Dawns
on me every single kid in the waiting
room was Asian I'm like oh
no you just said The Misfortune cook
okay bye and they would make you do a
scream as part a scream test it wouldn't
do it that's what they would do for Are
You Afraid of the Dark you do the
audition and you and my so then I
thought well you know and I just oh no
oh
no God cookie cookie s has for more
Fortune bad cookie bad cookie ah is this
what you wanted you made me do this he
got the role he did yeah that's why he
got his P
start he got the dub roll they rewrote
it for as Steven Wang
uh so before we move on to the Border
crisis and Hamas uh and the celebrations
in the west which of course everyone was
talking about but feel like we need to
cleanse the pallet a little bit RFK Jr
he needs to cleanse that pallet
permanently oh come on RFK Jr uh
announced now that he will be running in
2024 officially and a lot of people have
been talking about RFK Jr and I want to
know where you line up I think that a
lot there's always the person of the day
and he says things that you like but you
do have to look at his overall policies
and approaches and he's certainly not
lock step with the left but he certainly
is not someone who if you are
conservative I think you would be able
to justify voting for on closed handed
issues doesn't mean that he's a bad
person I just think that sometimes
people Overlook some pivotal uh pivotal
policy stances but he announced he is
going to run in 2024 now officially as
an independent we have a clip I don't
need anybody I'm I'm independent sorry
well supported by the American Dental
Association that was the wrong clip
nice here's right Cliff I'm going to
be I need my speech
[Laughter]
you you can't read anything you can't
read
[Applause]
anything high energy it's upside
down upside down it's upside down
May okay I'm sorry I'm sorry we we
started late today because of a
tricaster error here is tool man right
here is the right clip the right one
here I'm here to declare myself an
independent
candidate and his running mate Nick
Noti country oh hell got to fix make it
great again make America great again you
son of a it hurts my throat to
hear I know I think so bad
like H he needs to start using the
device just out of choice just I'm
running for
president I would vote for that dude I
don't care about the policies I just
want to hear that for four years the
speech is upside down like a pineapple
cake all
right and we want to get into the
history of third parties here because I
get a lot of people say the two- party
system man and this this is what's
important here but I also come from a
country I was raised there with a
parliamentary system where you can have
someone elected with not even close to a
majority of the vote so um I comment
below if you think that we need a third
party or if you believe that we need to
retake one party or keep one party
accountable obviously the Democrats are
lost permanently to the abyss the bog of
Eternal stench so here's a rundown
quickly on RFK Jr he accused the Dem uh
Democratic uh party of rigging the
primary wait no they would never do that
would never do that again yeah really
Bernie S I told you you sons of
I I appreciate he says the plural
correct I'm the OG VI of
ring he would be a great running mate he
would be a great running M now the views
that he has that are not aligned with
the left and you've probably really you
know he's been anti-id masas mask uh
mandates he supports an abortion ban
after the first trimester which look
he's not pro-life but he is the only
Democrat now he's an independent the
only Democrat I know of who has put a
reasonable limitation on abortion and
even though we don't agree
philosophically I
appreciate at least what he believes to
be a rational approach he believes in no
gender surgeries
certain
who modate he care though because the
Boogyman is still out there you know my
husband did not wrap up the nomination
in 1992 until he won the California
primary um somewhere in the middle of
June June right we all remember Bobby
Kennedy was assassinated in June in
California huh like a
veiled sounds like a
yeah odly like this making a murderer
why are you conflating the two like
Brandon dassie did you did you kill the
kennedies
yeah I shot the Kennedy yeah
yeah oh no but yeah
so and here's some of his uh I guess
views that wouldn't align with those on
the right U for example he supports
increased environmental regulations to
fight climate change okay you know that
that is one of those umbrellas that H
let's include anything else just put put
put that under put my name on there too
for some climate change money he still
thinks that racism is holding down black
Americans systemically and despite the
fact that he said gun control really
wouldn't meaningfully reduce gun
violence he would sign an assault
weapons ban bill if it reached his desk
which we all know was a disaster yeah
and and these are obviously incredibly
disappointing that last one is a
violation of one of your most basic
rights I mean look there's also the fact
that the Kennedy family needs another
relative in the White House like they
need another hole in their head Okay so
saying they need another cedy in the
White House oh oh wow there are
different ways to interpret
it that's
one sorry am I too mean no no no no no
no no I was think I had to think about
it okay it was like the Inception of
assassination well it wasn't a shotgun
plus where was Ted Cruz's where was Ted
Cruz's dad that day we don't know we
have no idea we don't know we still
don't know I'm just asking
questions if if no one's going to
ask questions then you know who's going
to ask questions on behalf of the
American people the bod okay the bod I
live in Mexico now in aasa so I get to
see things clearly right I wake up every
morning I go down to my farm fresh eggs
I eat
Migos I love how he the important
questions so third party spoilers are
there nothing new and here's the thing
you guys need to understand it's not
just consequence free like I don't like
vot third let's go to Trump vers Hillary
in 201 Gary Johnson completely straight
libertarian candidate Jill Stein they
did take votes from Hillary Clinton
swing States yeah that is to be clear so
that that one okay you know what they
even ran by the way I was like just
Stein I'm not complaining in 2000 you
had uh Bush versus Gore yeah right Ralph
nater got 1.6% of the Florida vote and
George W bush won Florida by
05% so again that probably would have
gone to gore at that point does Sting
for Gore don't worry he got he got a
Peace Prize for a film that a British
Court ruled had nine significant errors
and you know he said on the board of
Apple so yeah and it's also none of it
has come true thanks Al yeah exactly I
mean you know what the point is dreams
do come true and he can have Swedish
massas to his heart's content now here's
one male that was a really big deal uh
that you may not know if you're you know
jenz and we have a lot of young people
right now if you're watching do you know
about Ross peros 1992 Bush versus
Clinton Ross Pro actually got
18.9% of the popular vote and it's
incredibly impressive it could easily be
argued that you know George HW lost a
lot of states that he had previously won
so give you a good example Georgia Bush
lost by 6% perau got 133% to be clear he
was a much more conservative leaning C
he was bu people from Republican I
remember the campaigns as a kid I wasn't
even paying yeah he had the chicken like
build the sign and stuff like that it
was all this stuff it was really really
good and Dr Pepper MH uh then Ohio
George W bush lost by uh sorry George HW
Bush lost by Point uh sorry 1.9% do we
have that 1.9% perau got 21% of the vote
New Hampshire Bush lost by 1.3% perau
got 22% of the vote Pennsylvania Bush
lost by point or 9% he lost by 9% but
perau got 18% of the vote uh Bush lost
Michigan by 7% of the vote perau got
19% of the vote those are pretty
staggering numbers I no idea that he had
that big of an impact yeah huge impact
and that also reshaped the map as far as
swing States RFK he's like more he's not
like the the scheps Dr Pepper he's like
the RC Cola of the Pepsi challenge where
they give it to you did you ever do the
Pepsi challenge oh yeah where they go
hey which one they go which the two
different uh sodas like be like the
grocery store yeah they which one do you
like more and I would say well I'm
guessing you want me to say the only one
that's cold is that one the Pepsi
yeah it's been here for three days the
good news is though that all these
people they have something in common
right all the people were talking about
um aside from being old and white hey
what do you say we both be independent
together huh independent
now this goes back what do you think
about Donald Trump for example combining
with another Democrat people have said
tulsy gabard but are you aware of tulsy
gabbard's history on the assault weapons
ban right this is something that a lot
of people like to say I don't like
labels and so I want someone who's
independent but you do have to think of
the ramifications and I'd like for you
to comment especially anyone from Canada
or the UK two-party system is is is is
is flawed I get it it's absolutely but
would you rather have a parliamentary
system where different parties can form
this kind of a weird Coalition so for
example Trudeau professional black fe uh
blackface and chief he only got
32% of the popular vote Germany uh the
Prime Minister won with
25% of the popular vote so with with a
two-party system at least you have
someone who represents typically half of
most of Americans viewpoints at that
point in time in Germany you can have
someone who represents some of 25% of
the population and that's why these
governments have to have these monu
these tectonic shifts and changed their
entire system of government we are the
longest standing constitutional republic
in the world a lot of people are shocked
when I say that France they completely
changed their system Germany obviously
completely changed our system Canada
completely changed our system we have
kept the same one even though it's
flawed you had the wigs that turned into
the Republican party you need to swap
out a party with another party not have
three or take hold of the party that
claims to represent you and is instead
answering a special interest to me that
as a Republican party it doesn't mean
that I have an R next to my name or I
support anyone who has an R next to
their name but we have a better shot at
getting them out and getting someone in
who actually represents us that's just
my point I would love to hear what you
guys think RFK Jr seems like a decent
guy I can't listen to him very long I
have to clear my throat well I think
it's interesting to have him in because
I think he'll push Democrats to see some
of the flaws in what they're doing and
then I think it's interesting for us
because on the Republican side I think
he's stealing votes from Democrats and
not Republicans and I know a lot of
people say well he's got some
independent views I'm like yes but I
don't know that that is enough to sway
people right I really don't think it's
enough to take them away from a disantis
or Trump whoever gets the nominate Trump
he's got a commanding lead what do you
want me to say right now I'm sorry it's
never happened he only has the largest
lead ever yes exactly so I I get it and
by the way RFK was trailing uh uh by 47
points right in in the Democrat like if
he actually went up against Joe Biden
right so I understand how they're saying
like oh don't do this but you need to
let this process play out but I think
this is good for us I really do I think
it's good I think especially I mean I
understand that two bad things two bad
things one the launch was a little shaky
yes right we showed you that that's bad
you probably should have your ducks in a
row and two or your right side probably
should have uh pushed the launch date
yes no offense yes well in this case
he'll probably pull votes from both and
it'll be a wash that's my guess I think
he's going to pull more from Democrats
than Republicans I think Republicans are
voting Republican no matter what right
now Independents that lean Republican
are voting Republican you have for an
independent to vote for him they would
have to think that he
has I don't know I I I just I don't see
that really pulling him like I don't see
like he is so independent minded that
they're like yes that's my guy not
independent minded you know what I mean
like supports all of their polies enough
yeah I think it's Democrats going you
know what I don't like the crazy that I
see over here and I don't like Joe Biden
so I'm going to vote for him because
he's more like what I want you know what
the truth he's a Kennedy right so he'll
be fine if if he doesn't win he always
has the Island of Misfit
Toys the squirt gun that only shot jelly
that was an unsolvable problem Santa
sent those toys to osit did he you have
square Wheels oh exile for you you're
supposed to be generous and kind-hearted
not the Santa I knew not the Santa I
knew don't you remember that in Rudolph
he Wasing the elves we are Santa elves
he's like I can't I can't eat with all
that racket shut the
up trying to enjoy my
pie a little loud on the sorry about
that
you remember that right Sor such a dick
by the way the oldest constitutional
republic is actually San Marino we're
second well yeah but I don't know how
long they' Chang my point is I don't
know how how much they've radically
changed it like we still have the first
and second amendment we're we're better
than them anyway are are they even a
thing anymore I don't think they are I I
don't count those places or places like
Luxembourg never heard of San Marino
neither have IO Dan Marino Dan Dan
Marino let's have him go just launch
bomb at San Marino and problem selfs
solving Dan versus San yep I think it's
good I think we got Dan it's a
multilingual experience speaking of
multilingual let's talk about the border
wall now uh you're all talking about
Israel and Hamas and that is important
we are going to get to that but this is
also incredibly important uh this kind
of goes to the theme of today you know
oh diversity is our strength that's not
true diversity in and of itself is not a
strength that it's not necessarily even
a weakness it could be argued that
diversity for diversity sake certainly
is a weakness but the idea of just
bringing in people who aren't signing
the guest book there's no way to track
it kind of like money that goes to Hamas
from Iran there's no actual oversight
that in no way strengthens America and
then you end up with pockets of the
United States of America uh of terrorist
supporters but before we even get there
let's talk about how we actually have a
border and late last week former Vice
President Biden announced that he had
plans to allow this is a switch the
border wall construction to continue now
and and now the Department of Homeland
Security is saying that there is an
urgent and critical need to build
physical barriers to deal with this
influx and rise in illegal border
crossings this is a striking
acknowledgement that changes are needed
to stem the migrant influx at the
southern border President Biden planning
to now build more of the border wall a
major reversal from his campaign for
president saying he would never build
more of the wall ton Secretary of
Homeland Security Alejandra mayorca
saying quote there is an acute and
immediate need to construct physical
barriers and roads near the border okay
so before we we get into the the ins and
outs here and before we get to the the
moral problem of not actually having a
Without Borders you you don't have a
country let me just give you the
financial one for let's just even say
Libertarians out there because sometimes
you'll have Libertarians you'll say well
no it's actually good because it grows
the economy okay illegal immigration and
all the references are available at
l.com costs you the taxpayer $150
billion a year okay $150 billion a year
the border wall cost the approximate
estimate according to NPR what Donald
Trump wanted to build in full 11 billion
I've seen it as high as 20 billion yeah
so $1 150 billion do a year it costs you
the taxpayer versus a one-time cost of
let's call it 11 to20 billion how many
illegal Crossings have there been well
they've skyrocketed it was 2.2 million
in 2022 alone yeah how many and by the
way how many3 is saying hold my beer
right yes that's more than the whole
population of Phoenix yeah over 1
million people trafficking victims gez
so let's just drug trafficking while
we're talking about that at over
55 sorry 550,000 yeah pounds that's a
lot of nut of drugs seized at the border
so far and I know the Libertarians say
well if we just legalize all drugs I'm
sure the cartel will straighten up and
fly right or they'll just traffic More
Humans because they're criminals let's
be honest about let's be honest Lou you
paid for the women border patrol is
having a huge party now name that movie
line yeah so let's go through the claims
and the truths and this is one that's
near and dear to your heart because you
know you live right near the the open
border wall really I do
yeah hey can I just throw something in
and we'll get to it in just a second but
uh you have a good AR borders walls
things like that they tend to work uh
Egypt just closed theirs actually with
oh they did yeah oh Egypt Egypt uh you
know has pretty much had the same kind
of policy that Israel has had at at at
the wall there with Gaza I don't know if
people remember Gaza actually bordered
Egypt as well so if there's a problem
they should be protesting Egypt maybe
equally you would think so I would think
because they can escape that way no no
because apparently walls work and by the
way next time my orchus does a quote on
this don't say barriers need to be
erected say the word wall yeah I want it
to hurt yes wall I'm okay with like a
fence if there's razor wire and a wall
behind the fence so that way it's
demoralizing or like they climb and they
like they're like I made it through the
razor wire it's like there still a wall
oh
no with more razor wire yeah with more
razor wire yeah as a matter of fact you
give them like the bat rope to scale the
wall only it's a razor
wire soaked in kerosene yes now why
would anyone soak a rope in kerosene how
much for an invisible wall oh that would
be nice that would be great that would
be hilarious Ste wall just everyone
walking AC walking across El Paso with
bruises on their forehead I don't know
looking like a bird in your door so
let's go through the claims versus the
truth as we're dealing with the border
wall uh here's a claim that they make
okay that there is no crisis at the
border here you go do you believe that
right now there's a crisis the Border I
think that the uh um the answer is no uh
I think there is a challenge at the
border that we are managing and and we
have our resources dedicated to to
managing it I think the answer is no but
here's the truth when America said that
at that time 173,000 crossed that month
alone now in August of 2023 it was over
232,000 by the way mostly single adults
ah not women and children no it's mostly
people you would find on on on Tinder on
terrrace watch lists yes H well not I
don't want to say all terrorist watch
list some could be landscapers watch
list now
the average under Donald Trump 40,000 a
month the scale matters so when he said
no I don't believe we have an emergency
173,000 cross that month compared to the
average under Donald Trump 40,000 he
knows that and now we're at 232,000 Jes
40,000 232,000 think about that first at
what point does it become a crisis let
comment below at what point if you don't
think it's a crisis at what point is
what's the number yeah give number
400,000 is it 500,000 a month is it 10
million people a year what is it that's
four times as many as as Donald Trump
was let ACR that's four times as many
four times as many that's a lot are we
at the point where people talk about the
economy can we also acknowledge too as
it relates to immigration I mean the
economy we talked about International
right National Security Foreign
Relations like are we at that point now
we go okay this was all objectively
better than it is right now and by the
way yesterday the house Judiciary
Committee released a report claiming
that Biden has failed to remove over
99% of illegal immigrants who have been
released in the United States I don't
remember releasing 99%
99% that just means they're assuming
there's at least one guy yes exactly
there's one guy that got handles one guy
who got bored got lost on his way back
he was still using Map Quest
congratulations you're in the 1% yes we
actually took you out of the country yes
son of a gun he told me to take a light
R slight ride I don't know what that
means but now I'm back
inana so here's another claim that they
will make and we're just going going to
Rattle through these claims and truths
so you know these are completely untrue
all the references are available you're
welcome illegal immigrants right should
uh actually go to they'll say this
because this is the virtue signal it's
like actually illegal immigrants should
go to the places that support them us
the Democrats right migrant loving
Sanctuary liberal cities that's their
claim this is horrific when you think
about uh What uh the governor uh is
doing the governor of Texas uh after a
month of traveling across the border
placing on the us with no direction to
come here uh to New York and New York is
a city that has always represented the
democratic values and the values of our
city of showing our compassion and
that's what we're doing today oh they
should come to your cities here's the
truth uh actually they really
shouldn't places like New York really
are at capacity you know we have large
Hearts want to be generous and
supportive to people who are
experiencing not if it read No Vacancy
but there is the firefighters come in
and say we're at our limit we were going
to have a shelter at this particular
[Applause]
[Music]
location not for
[Applause]
long hundreds of Queens Village
residents rallied outside creedmore
Psychiatric Center Tuesday night where
humanitarian tents are almost ready
foring men to move in we got a vacation
they have to somewhere else right we we
cannot we don't have the services to
take care of 50 immigrants she's
basically telling that reporter that
she's not going to take
it no we can't handle 50 50 remember 50
you can't handle 50 like oh no no oh no
no 50 no that's just the van we said
50,000 yeah that's a that's a quarter of
this month mhm I love that we can't
handle 50 we just can't possibly do it
it's always rules for thee not for me
and this is a thing by the way this is a
winning issue this is important don't
allow anyone in the left to tell you oh
you should be afraid of being accused of
being racist no no this is a winning
issue in the election illegal
immigration even for Suburban white
housewives just to be clear here's
another claim that they're going to make
to try and Gaslight you uh former Vice
President Biden has said that border
wall construction um is resuming now
only because so he doesn't he wants
there to be the border wall to be clear
because you guys need it but he still
needs to Virtue signal to his his
constituents and say it's only resuming
now because my hands and by the way it's
very easy to tie his hands like you you
could just do it you could do it with a
a PO and peel
Twizzler just it's resuming only cuz my
hands are tied huh wall the money was
appropriated for the border wall I tried
to get them to reappropriate to redirect
that money they didn't they and in the
meantime there's nothing under the law
other than they have to use the money
for what it appropriate okay I can't
stop that you can't stop it yeah well
well here's the truth um the B
administration had to wave 26 federal
laws and regulations largely their own
in order for construction to restart
these come from you know Obama and of
course for vice president got examples
right here yeah we have the Clean Water
Act that's Democrat legislation you have
The Endangered Species Act you have the
Safe Water drinking act safe water
drinking act for a wall on the border
how did they shoehorn that in I don't
about the Rio Grande like you know what
just get a what what are those things
called the emergency straws life straws
get a life straw life straw you're fine
things are better they're not a sponsor
but I've heard good things I love I love
that this administration's like a we we
have to I'm sorry like yeah this has
never really worked for you in the past
anyway we have to wave 26 federal laws
and regul that's more laws than
Democrats wave to steal the last
election and we're allowed to talk about
it on YouTube now it's okay Mohan so
their hands were tied for that too hey
we just stole the we couldn't help it
there's nothing I can there's nothing I
can can do these are your laws we
actually have footage from behind the
scenes of former Vice President Biden
meeting with his homeland security team
excuse me sir but you're breaking your
own laws what what do you think
what I have been
bambard you ever go back and watch some
of your childhood favorites and realize
how gay some of the voice actors are
they are I'm going to be a dentist sure
you are excuse me sir about your
breaking it's a difficult respons
ability you're going to get monkey pox
yes yes I say Mr Burg master master why
don't we why don't we simply drop some
acid and go to a techn music festival
and see what comes of
[Laughter]
it I'll keep
going that's a mean that the younger
ones technov Viking that was terrifying
okay I remember yeah technov Viking was
the man he was the man yeah do send him
to Gaza yes what is he doing I don't
know he'll save everybody he's so
unpredictable the man doesn't play by
anyone's rules not even his
own do you think they have like Hamas do
you think they have like a cabretti or
they have like a dirty hay like it's
time to bring in
Mas dirty Habib yes dirty Habib are you
feeling lucky punk yeah go ahead make my
Ramadan all right
fine by the way Peter Ducey
was that was so silly I'm
sorry Peter Ducey was obviously
perturbed by this and you just
completely flabbergasted I love this
jier uh when I love to know if she
actually speaks French nope he asked her
about this whole thing with the wall he
said there will not be another foot of
Wall constructed in my Administration so
something changed what you want us to
break the law is that what you want you
want us to not comply with the law I'm
not I'm asking but you want us to not
comply with the law you want us to not
be an administra follow you guys do this
all the time the student loans uh the
student loan forgiveness program uh you
went to court to fight for that if this
is such a problem building 20 mil of
wall why not just go to court we went to
Congress the Congress appropriates the
funding Congress Congress appropriates
the funding we asked them to not use
that funding for that particular purpose
they denied it and now we're complying
with the law if you have to build a
border wall but you don't think that
it's going to work then once it's done
are you just going to tear it down I'm
not getting into hypotheticals from here
oh it's not it's not so much a
hypothetical like there's an actual wall
I love this moment because D's like what
you want to comply with the you don't
care about the law he used stent loan
forgiveness and he didn't kind of stick
it he mumbled it a little bit former
President Biden said we know that the
Supreme Court is going to rent
forgiveness was the same thing they were
like yeah we really don't care about
what the law say Supreme Court will
overturn it in 3 months but at least
that'll give us three more months and
then he's like oh wait a minute I'll
cancel more student debt it really is a
world that doesn't live in reality the
left of today I mean you know there are
no men and women right male female is a
that that that that swinging dick
between your legs is a figment of your
imagination the idea that laws of rent
forgiveness think about that for a
second it's like okay I signed a lease
agreement and I owe uh $500 in in rent
yeah no you don't what nothingness
yeah for three months how how does that
work it doesn't ex there's no way for
this to actually be congruent with
reality and B yeah I know that student
loan for hold on a second was there
someone working was there a professor
working and I get that schools
especially higher education the costs
are bloed was someone working was
someone providing a service were there
books that were purchased oh yeah so
money is owed no it's not your
imagination and by the way look if this
is going to happen if he's saying that
this money was appropriated back in 2018
under Donald Trump maybe you don't make
such a sticking point of not one more
inch of wall will be built maybe don't
do that yeah because then when you have
to build the wall which you knew you
were going to have to do and kind of
follow the law for the first time in
your administration's history you look
like an idiot well he also did say now
despite they are they are building the
wall more I'm at a slower rate but at
the same time former Vice President
Biden said we're building something that
doesn't work walls don't work do you
believe the border wall Works
no but I'm going to build we're going to
build it can you expand on that because
every other country on the planet
believes they work and they have
evidence so please help me what does you
mean walls don't
work walls do work by the way even here
can we check it we we have to use them
all the time in the office they're out
there right
[Music]
now
and that wasn't even that expensive of a
of a wall they work poor little guy
walls don't work how about the one you
built between him and his granddaughter
he never
sees yeah I think they work and I bet
you was actually daughter would have
liked a shower wall yeah just a nice
little maybe even a glass one just a
glass preferably not but you know it's
better than that sun likes a dry wall
yeah exactly he does it's a family
entirely obsessed with walls yeah I like
a wet wall a dry wall a border wall I
particularly like a lead wall that lead
pain I like smoking M you see
so here's the thing he's doing this now
and they never call the issue is they
never call them to the mat it's the
accountability issue which is what we're
going to get to as it relates to Hamas
celebrations uh Across the Western World
former he undermined wall construction I
mean all the time it's an election issue
and then they all of a sudden sudden
have to live in reality kind of like all
of the Democrats say no we're not we
hate war and then there you look at
Barack where is code pink the only
president who didn't start a new war was
Donald Trump but we were in a Prett much
kept everybody else in their neutral
Corners kept them in their neutral
corners but then they all of a sudden
get their first homeland security
briefing and go oh I mean they probably
hear the theme from Homeland in the
background as they soil their pants it's
the same thing with the wall they said
we don't need it until they go wait the
number is what 232,000 so he undermined
this just back in August in August the
Biden Administration they sold 150 more
uh $154 million of border wall materials
at auction knowing by the way I just I
just want to say this knowing that they
weren't going to be able to get Congress
to change their minds right and they
sold it so I want to know what the
number is and maybe it was in that quot
to so research what's it going to cost
us to buy it back because typically at
auction you don't pay top dollar
typically you get a bit of a deal right
well the good news is we can we can buy
it back from El Chapo well no I
guarantee what's going to happen is the
companies that produce that kind of
stuff and sell it went out there and
like sure I mean you paid me 100 bucks
I'll pay I'll pay 60 I'll give you 60
cents on the dollar 60 bucks you're
going to be back in two months to buy it
again price went up though 120 good news
the cost of bord wall construction just
went up 112%
today inflation's never been lower
right uh and by the way the state of
Texas I do you know Governor Abbott does
some good things does some things that
are sometimes questionable but uh they
bought $6 Million worth of materials and
ab even called he's a wheelchair guy by
the way he's a bargain shoer he even
called a special session about the
Border um saving him from setting forth
by the way what was initially his backup
plan yeah it was that court is far too
long really really you're you're going
to be pulling it for a while Grandma
so and hit the like button by the way if
you're watching right now on YouTube or
on Rumble do consider joining M Club
lit.com you get a full other hour of
show today Friday show Alex Jones Show
on Friday you get the Hodge twin weekly
show Brian K weekly show guns and gear
our investigative journalism unit all of
thiso every day every day he's become a
favorite of and comment below if you've
been watching Nick at 500 pm. by the way
he's a strong R I let you know but I had
someone and the Hodge twins truly are
uncensored yes they truly are oh Lord
help but this is one of those issues
that you have to bear the burden let's
again let's recap this the cost to you
the taxpayer of illegal immigrants in
this country $150 billion a year border
wall cost call 11 to 20 billion depend
the most generous estimate is about 20
something billion dollar the number of
border crossings 2.2 million people in
2022 Alone 1 million of whom were
trafficked victims and over 550,000
pounds of drugs this year alone geez by
the way you want to know the the
scariest part of this what about the
people that are coming over you think
it's it's the women and children that
we've been told it's not its military
agen but what about they're not all from
Venezuela they're not all from Nicaragua
they're not not all from mexic Meo by
the way there's there's a bit of this
kind of train that comes over so they go
down to Cairo if you can make your way
to Cairo as a terrorist you can come in
through I believe Ecuador because they
are a visalist state and then you can
just basically make your way North into
the United States you want to see Hamas
in a theater near you I I certainly
don't I certainly don't want terrorism
coming to our major cities because we
have the balls to stand up for Israel
and to say here's what's right maybe
cutting off kids heads yeah at concerts
is probably a bad idea for Freedom
Fighters I didn't realize that that was
a a legitimate military Target people
that were listening to techn music like
do you want that in the United States
maybe we should start focusing on the
border it's not just people coming in
and taking landscaping jobs like some
people could say fine whatever I don't
care yeah I care about militants coming
into our country and killing our
citizens well not not only that if you
say people say well we need a much
easier process for people to to
immigrate to this country I don't
necessarily know that I agree but even
if you believe that let me ask you this
do you think that people who legally
come to this this country right and they
go through the process let's assume that
it was simpler do you think they would
want to be burdening the $150 billion in
annual cost of illegal immigrants the
only way that you fix it if you have a
hole in a boat is you got to plug the
hole in the boat you have to plug that
hole in the boat other the bucket's not
going to be enough and the hole is going
to grow larger and yes it is a national
security issue yeah it if you talk about
abusive women it's a sex trafficking
issue it's a drug issue these people
love to talk about they they find Common
Ground fentanyl crisis yeah we're all
against sex trafficking yeah we're all
against actual Islamic terrorism okay
but why aren't you doing anything to
stop it this is one of the central
pivotal issues and that's going to bring
us to our next segment on Hamas and the
pro terrorism celebrations but really
quickly let's check in to see how our
walls are doing with that
[Music]
Roomba
all right cute little somero okay I mean
it doesn't even have to be that good of
a wall I guess just just something is
better than nothing do it doesn't yeah
that's why I don't always fear AI
now that guard wasn't even paying
attention I want to make sure I have
these uh these numbers um correct here
but before we get to the celebrations
that you've seen across the globe and
again my question to you is have you
seen celebrations Pro Hamas Pro
terrorism celebrations in your neck of
the woods I sound like Al Roker but the
good thing is he does he actually has a
neck now after the lap band he had a had
the the the the thing for a little bit
yeah now he's better okay yeah so there
are about 1.8 billion Muslims in the
world all right now I get this I want to
lead this off with okay of course not
everyone supports uh terrorism or the
ideology or the extermination of all
Christians and Jews but too many of them
do as a percentage too many of them do
as a percentage and let me go let me go
back further uh Muhammad did we've
talked about this you and I have done
sketches on this right not Muhammad the
sketch that we did on YouTube back in
the day because F were concerned um
those were Muhammad's dying words that's
true Muhammad's dying words were calling
for the deaths of all Christians and
Jews now there are some Muslims who give
those words less weight or interpret it
differently okay absolutely but those
words are there and those words are in
the Quran and that's why you have 8%
according to Pew Muslims believe that
violence against civilians is at least
sometimes Justified that me that roughly
198 million Muslims support the use of
violence just to be clear dang go go
back to so there's a number of 3%
believe violence against civilians is
often Justified meaning they totally
believe it 8% believe violence against
civilians is sometimes Justified now if
PW doesn't go in deeper I guarantee you
that 8% that would be a larger
percentage of is violence Justified for
example against someone who has painted
a portrait of Muhammad that number would
be higher than 8% that's the most milk
toast kind of review that you can see of
what they believe but just so that just
that 3% number those people that are
really bought in when you're saying like
look it's only 3% of our religion that's
54 million people around the world 50 it
doesn't take 54 million right to make
things it let's use the real number 198
million who believe that violence
against civilians sometimes Justified
not violence against soldiers 198
million sometimes I guess if he's like
really a dick yeah they're probably
supporting those causes financially so
that sometimes is is like yeah sure I
would give money to these organizations
that are doing this yes and 200 million
let me read you these quotes too from
Hadith by the way um just to be clear
and you you know this better than I do
um Gerald but uh here's one the last
hour won't come before the Muslims would
fight the Jews and the Muslims will kill
them so Jews would hide behind the rocks
and trees then the rocks and trees would
call oh Muslim o servant of God there's
Jew behind me come and kill him only uh
garad tree it is of the Jews trees and
let's also find there are the also I
don't believe that was those were the
last words of Muhammad I believe that's
a no that was just a Hadith and by the
way just so you understand what a Hadith
is like think of it as like a helps like
like like a some kind of a kind of book
that tells you what scripture means
except Muslims Elevate Hadith basically
almost to the same level of scripture
and that's something that's unique for
us we don't Elevate anything to the same
level of scripture in Christianity right
but they do so this has the same kind of
effect as scripture in most it would be
similar to let's say like the Book of
Mormon and I'm not saying this by the
way I'm saying this because the Book of
Mormon to Mormons who they identify
themselves as Christians but they take
the Book of Mormon to also be prophetic
right that adds to the Bible they add
the Bible with the Quran very very
different your biggest problem is with
the Book of Mormon people out there who
are not Mormon and I understand them
we've done a segment on that I am not
Mormon I know a lot of Mormons who are
good people the Quran is distinctly more
violent yes and they took the more
violent version of it yeah there were 26
copies of the Quran they basically
pulled them all together burned them and
came out with one that was the most
violent rendition it seems of the book
and when they tell you that you cannot
read the Quran unless you you are
actually fluent in Arabic uh they say
that but because they want you to feel
as though there's this elit like you
can't actually it's actually far more
violent if you understand it and you
read it in Arabic the original
translation in Arabic is is worse just
so you know starts out kind of peaceful
and you're like oh well this is not so
bad but then later on it it's somebody
was having a bad day now I understand
there are lots of Muslims who don't
right just as there are different
denominations in Christianity but
190 plus million do believe that
violence against civilians is at least
sometimes
Justified and you would just think this
is one of those deals where um
immediately after you know the raping of
women and and killing of children
hundreds of Israelis innocent Israelis
targeted you would think that maybe the
people who are the pro Palestine
demonstrators would just put a pause on
it m this is there's such a lack of
fearing any accountability they don't
care about the Optics again because the
ideology stems from just eradicating
Jews period and you are seeing in many
Western cities these massive Pro Hamas
uh demonstrations celebrations of death
Across the Western
[Applause]
[Music]
world that's Toronto for people watching
I know you think
[Applause]
Gaza there's anti-
techno they must really hate that
techno and by the way just this just in
right now just in the across the country
where this stuff is happening the UN
actually recognized a moment of silence
here go ahead and bring that up when you
have it so moment of silence for
Palestine ah get out of here not truth
and moment of silence for Palestine I'm
sorry hey uh do me a favor guys uh
search and see if they did one for
Israel I'm sure they must have yeah I
mean maybe they forgot to tweet it or
maybe they forgot to actually hold the
moment of silence but somebody just
missed it they are one of the Nations
United yeah you would think so you would
think H you're having a moment of for a
nomination and by the way let's see what
happens in these other countries uh that
they have like they have hate speech so
you notice you don't see that these
kinds of protests take place you don't
see them in Tokyo you don't see them in
Soul you don't see them in Taipei Warsaw
Budapest just to be clear these are
taking place and they're escalating in
American and in Canadian CI uh cities
with well I I'm assuming citizens I
don't know they could have just come
over that giant gaping hole on the
border yeah who knows but there are some
people out there who aren't just those
celebrators of death right it's not just
nameless face there's celebrities and
politicians who are also out there uh
pimping the Hamas message so let's go
first to Mia and I wasn't super familiar
with her but I know she is she was a
pornography actress I knew khif but only
you know from music so she put this out
there can someone please tell me the
freedom fighters in Palestines to flip
their phones and film horizontal I just
want to make it clear that this
statement in no way shape or form is
enticing spread of violence I
specifically said Freedom Fighters
because that's what the Palestinian
citizens are fighting for Freedom every
day well I guess here's the thing if you
mean uh Freedom
Fighters
[Music]
I I believe she was under the false
impression that the Gaza Strip was
perhaps a gentleman's club that's what I
understand and they maybe she was a
little bit confused oh come on but there
is for people on audio it's just just
either go back or you don't you have to
here is a slightly happy ending though
uh she was immediately fired from her
yes from her uh job as an ambassador for
I guess a mushroom company the CEO
thought this was a code for something
else no the CEO Todd
Shapiro here's a surprise that Shapiro
was upset about that a Shapiro when she
put out that message about Hamas and she
ring ring it's Shapiro she had to go oh
that's not
good this is going to be this day is
going to cost getting a raise he set
this out publicly he said this is such a
horrendous tweet Mia consider yourself
fired effective immediately simply
disgusting beyond disgusting please
evolve and become a better human being
you know lofty goals I don't think
that's by the way she's a mushroom sales
I don't know like there's all now
mushroom it's all about mushrooms
nowadays I don't I didn't know it was
the thing so I thought it get in the
game Gerald but she did get fired from
Playboy as well right I don't know if
you saw that like there were like that
happened and I'm like my mushroom
company's got to be a euphemism for
something like they should have made hey
they should have had a spread with her
like a burka but you know nothing
underneath
they did that I mean I don't
know they wrote about it the article
yeah yeah I heard about it yeah and
let's go to our favorites uh you know
what let's bring up that quote do we
have the quote Muhammad right the The
Last Words the dying words from Hadith
just again this is like hey is last call
is uh uh let's bring it up there uh Matt
because I don't have it in front of me
do it now do it all right so expel the
Jews of the hij and from the Arabian
Peninsula and know that the most evil of
people are those took the graves of
their prophets as places of worship
there you go expel the
Jews yeah the graves of their Prophet a
little bit different from like Jesus
like you know love don't I was being
Muhammad Jesus is like love one another
F you know I mean I don't know his last
words might have been like his last
words might have been something you know
that wasn't documented where he's just
like yeah I know you can put your you
can put your finger through it all right
I'll see in a little bit but I think
Jesus last words was uh BRB yeah BRB yes
exactly he's like yeah the Jews won't
believe it that's a whole other thing I
know I'm one of them but it'll sort
itself out don't worry I'll give him
another chance yeah so um I say that
because Ilan Omar and Rashid T would
probably be amongst those 198 million
now why do I say that there's right
there's some kind of a a check or
balance in that they can't just come out
and say hey we support we celebrate the
death this is what these protests are
let's be they're not protests they are
death celebrations yeah mhm steal just
let me let me remind you if you if you
forgot what they were celebrating so
there the the concert goers running and
screaming being shot people just random
people like they're going door Todo
killing kids in front of parents and
then kidnapping those parents and taking
them into Gaza I'm saying what Israel
has put out right now has happened
burning people Alives alive in their
homes because they couldn't get in to
actually get them out uh and one of the
most frightening terrifying things is
finding children's heads removed from
their bodies in these homes yeah that's
what these people are out in the streets
cheering for that's what they think
Justice is and there's a big difference
between a bomb or a missile being fired
at a military base yeah and that is
usually by the way hidden in a grade
school and it's a tragedy absolutely
right a child is is dead but child is
dead from a missile that was aimed at a
military base and a child's had
personally separated by human
hands because they're Jewish that's
that's what just to be clear that is
what Hamas does that is what they we're
not talking about some longrange missile
they show up and they saw the heads off
children and I mean it's not even always
necessarily a clean cut I advise you to
not go and do the research because there
videos out there it's horrifying
researchers came out said 40 babies uh
found dead yep 40 That's those are
Freedom Fighters and then these
celebrations and that brings us to Anan
Omar and Rashida TB and by the Wayan
Omar banged and married her brother just
look up the marriage certificate gross
Omar uh this was her tweet I guess on X
she said this is this is Omar yeah this
this is collective punishment a war
crime and the US should oppose any
violations of international law if we
support a rules-based international
order because she sounds like Rafiki hey
hold on a
second doesn't the war crime Clause go
out the window when they decapitate your
children by Design I don't know I mean
two war crimes from Hamas right because
they fired from civilian areas into
civilian areas my my my policy on that
at that point is um screw Hugh and by
any means necessary to take out Hamas
period let's go to T from my uh former
home state lengthy Instagram statement
she of course placed the blame on Israel
right the path to that future must
include lifting the blockade ending the
occupation and dismantling the aparti
system that creates the suffocating
dehumanizing conditions that can lead to
resistance maybe she's talking about
Egypt oh no that's right just the Jews
as long as our country provides billions
in unconditional funding to support the
apartheid government this heartbreaking
cycle of violence will continue in other
words she's starting off with point of
fact unless Israel gives more land
repeatedly as they have already done we
can all assume that the violence will
continue really would would the violence
continue if Hamas put down their arms
just to be clear Israel left guys in
2005 mhm and then they started some more
up again and started launching
missiles and they said well you don't
get that anymore it's kind of like with
my with my son I give him a toy and if
he like hits his sister with it I go you
play with that toy anymore why because I
gave it to you and you hit your sister
with it now you get no toy you get no
Gaza I know right the minute the and by
the way Gaza was saying leave let us
govern ourselves so Israel's like okay
fine fine we're going to leave we're
going to let you guys govern yourselves
because we're apparently bad immediately
they elected Hamas yep how has let me
just let me just ask you we go from
president to president Administration to
Administration Congress to Congress and
we go is life better is your life better
than
2005 I would I would wager that it's not
because you guys have said that this is
an open air
prison of your own making and no no and
of your Muslim Brothers making because
they won't let you in their country
either yeah who should you really be mad
at right now you know Israel yeah you
know the only Muslims who aren't in open
air prisons uh Muslims who live in
Israel right that's one thing that you
often forget about by the way lots of
them by the way lots of Arab Muslims
that live peacefully in Israel and
Israel is like a okay with it just as
long as you're not going to shoot up or
blow up we're fine yep and by the way
here's the outside of T's Washington
office if we just bring yeah notice I
don't know if you notice any
contradictions I would love to see her
grab that rainbow flag and run down to
Hamas front lines like the Patriots
patri
with like so did you want to kill you
want to kill her first we we need to
buildings apparently I'm so confused she
has the traditional headress but the
flag what do we do I don't know I
don't know how's she so fat
was was there even an American flag
there nope that's the point no stars and
or Stripes right there now maybe there
were on the other side maybe there were
maybe it's just so funny that she has
the lgbtq flag and Palestine there
because they would burn her aive drag
her behind truck send her back send her
I think it's only fair that they get
like a little cultural enrichment you
know like a foreign exchange program
yeah they should we take in exchange we
don't need anything in exchange is a
free GI M and she goes there with that
flag and stays away from tall buildings
yeah like like like a pen pal program
only we make her the pen pal from there
we send her over and now you get to be
our pen pal by the way we've uh just so
you know we've shipped all of your
Rainbow uh all of your Rainbow flags all
of your Rainbow paraphernalia and it
will arrive um very publicly wrapped so
that everyone knows exactly Hamas will
know exactly they exactly package at the
same time and we hope for the best yes
let's read this from Harvard the beacon
of higher education again you see the
celebrations of death in the streets and
you can say Ah that's just a small
amount of people 198 million Muslims
across the world who support violence
sometimes against civilians now we have
Harvard a joint statement by 35
groups we the undersigned student
organizations hold the Israeli regime
entirely responsible for all unfolding
violence all all and entirely
responsible hey look how about maybe
like if you want to say
some
right I'm just entirely all of it at
least try to hide your anti-Semitism and
that's not the worst part sure it's
really dumb I mean even your lawyers
will tell you to couch your words like
we'll try and avoid words like always
and all and never because it gives them
just a little bit of leeway and I think
in this case you know 700 people and 40
babies who are dead and decapitated you
know might might might there might might
stand a reason that someone might have a
counterargument to any and all violence
but here's the crazy part I've always
said it's not just that people say this
when they say it so boldly and loudly
that they don't actually even take into
consideration the remote possibility of
accountability there has been no
condemnation or backlash from the
Harvard Administration none
whatsoever at 11
11:22 Eastern what's the date today we
the 16th we no the 10th 10th the 10th
you're an entire week off I'm an entire
week
off none so far bring really quickly
bring that back up so so this is
Lawrence Summers a former Harvard
president long time Washington Economic
Policy hand it nothing has happened so
far and I believe he actually took to X
to excoriate har Harvard for saying this
and saying like you you can't you have
to distance yourself from people like
this who say Israel is completely to
blame by the way if Israel goes in and
kills children I feel the same way about
that yeah don't misunderstand what I'm
saying it's not like Israel can do no
wrong they do plenty of wrong we're just
saying when people come in and start
shooting up concerts and decapitating
babies you put all that aside and go
those are the bad guys we're going after
them yep sorry that's just that just is
what it is you can talk about the rest
of this stuff later on once the
beheading of babies and killing of
concert goers is done with right and
let's go to the media as well and by the
way the media has has it started off
where they had to say our hearts are
with Israel and then just give it a
little bit of time New York Times here's
a uh headline there Gaza has
suffered under 16-year blockade
why the
blockade Forbes and this was deleted by
the way where they actually wrote Hamas
threatens to execute Israeli civilian
hostages for unprompted Attack on Gaza
look if you want to say and you want to
go all the way back to the Old Testament
and say okay it was their landed it was
their fine but to say unprompted attack
on Gaza again it's not just that someone
wrote this at Forbes it's that they
think so little of you the American
public you watching listening their not
you I guess their reader on average that
they think they re is going to go yeah
completely unprompted attack on c yeah
that makes sense yeah sure yeah publish
that Washington Post their Global
opinions editor uh Karen
ataya likeed this tweet what did yall
think decolonization meant Vibes papers
essays
losers these same people then so let me
ask you this does that mean that you
want Native Americans to Massacre women
and children here because you believe
that we've colonized it exactly and also
can you hold that position while also
bitching about the fact that more
effective
civilizations came in and populated a
continent comment below how do you hold
those two positions oh anti okay you
know what all right you want to do that
you want to do if you are saying that
being anti-colonialist what did you
think it was going to be it means
violence great so then does that mean
that us the colonialists we can use the
same violence too because we have more
guns we're the people of AR-15s just to
be clear we won we won once we'll do it
again the coverage is so bad that uh
this guy uh greenblat of the ADL who we
is don't like this guy we don't like
this guy this guy's an absolute wiener
we use the ADL for the hate symbol are
not game because they're so absurd
they're idiots even for him this is this
is too far of a bridge for him to cross
I'll be honest I am angry I am angry
with the world that allowed the
dehumanization of Israelis and sanitized
the terrorism of Kamas I must say I love
this show and I love this network but
I've got to ask who is right in the
scripts Hamas the people who did this
they are not Fighters Jonathan they are
not militants and I'm looking right at
the camera they are terrorists it is a
barbarian who rapes and brutalizes women
who tear kills children in front of
their
parents so just think of the time bomb
the ticking Time Bomb we've created here
in the United States we have an open
border we don't know who's coming in we
have media we have higher education
establishments who go out there and
support terrorist sympathizers
unfettered
completely and at the same time so
that's these are all the mistakes that
we've made 198 million Muslims self-
professed Muslims in the world today who
support violence against
civilians if were
198,000 I'd be concerned mhm 1.9 million
I like oh maybe we're getting to 19
million I say okay okay we have to do
million support sometimes violence
against civilians over 15 million uh
sorry 50 million support often violence
against civilians sure not all Muslims I
get it it's not even a majority of
Muslims across the globe but it's too
much and it's certainly too much when we
can't keep track of the people who
support violence against our civilians
coming into this country now let's also
go back because we see these
celebrations of death do you remember
when one French Muslim was killed in a
traffic stop the entire country
descended into riots at the flip
[Music]
[Applause]
side
and so so hold on a second one person is
killed in
tragedy you start celebrations parties
of
death when your side terrorists kill
hundreds of innocent women and children
you then start parties of death and
celebrations of death where's the life
in any of
it do this is something a lot of people
miss when we talked with uh we talked
about Dr Ben Carson at one point he
caught all this Flack where he said
actually I believe that Sharia law is
completely incompatible with the he said
it's completely incompatible with the
Constitution he just the only reason
that guy didn't make it for this he's
like audio ambient I listen to his audio
books every
night but he said it's completely
incompatible with the Constitution why
because it's a prescription of laws
Sharia law which by the way exists in
one capacity or another in every major
Islamic nation in the world and these
laws of course always violate basic
rights of women always violate basic
rights of people who are gay minorities
they're not talk about systemic
discriminate they don't care it's based
on systemic discrimination and based on
systemic discrimination not only on Race
but on your faith do you know what diud
is do you know what that is do you know
what the PO tax is you know what the
curfew is if you're not a Muslim under
Sharia law of course it is incompatible
with the Constitution and before we even
get to the 198 million people who
support sometimes death for civilians
bet you that numbers a lot higher as far
as Muslims who if they had their way
would support you paying a pole tax as a
Christian or a Jew or a curfew or being
limited and your property rights or
where you can travel that is all a part
of sharia law and is completely
incompatible with the Constitution but
the Constitutional Scholars at Harvard
are not going to tell you about that
this is genocide to be clear people you
know what's not genocide what happened
with the Native Americans here there was
a lot of shitty stuff Happening by the
way uh the white settlers and of course
even you can go to the conistor I am not
defending them full stop we just had col
we just had uh uh indigenous people's
day or was it yesterday Columbus day
yesterday trying to remember it was a
different day it was also Canadian
Thanksgiving but nobody cares but just
to be clear that's not genocide if it
were genocide Johnny Depp wouldn't be
118th
commanche there would be no comman there
would be we wouldn't have more Native
Americans today than ever in history
there were bloody battles there were
some underhanded tactics used on both
sides absolutely but it wasn't proactive
genocide and that it was never a matter
of and this is how you know know the
left perverts they accuse others of
doing exactly what it is that they do or
they support they accuse the founding
fathers who by the way or pilgrims they
accuse conservatives who are proud of
their country of supporting genocide as
though it was a matter of policy to go
forward and wipe out any last
that was never a policy the
policy was actually assimilation inter
Mar because we have people who are very
industrious and we wanted we wanted to
be a part of I don't know if you know
this when talk about the Conquistadors
you know how many came over about 500
you know how many natives there were
hundreds of
thousands you know how they were taken
up was because half of them had been in
and by the way I don't know if you know
this about like the Mayans the Incas
right the Aztecs they had giant caves
filled with gold how do you think they
got that gold you get them gold you are
enslaved or you no longer live so they
said we're going to take our chances
with the guys in the funny metal hats
that wasn't genocide it required enough
natives to take out other natives
because they were tired of living under
slavery so I say this because they'll
try and teach your kids that America is
based upon genocide when actual genocide
today actual genocide by that I mean the
prescribed policy of the extermination
and or eradication which is almost
redundant of all Jews in other words
Hamas Hezbollah their goal is not
complete until there is not one Jew or
Christian left
period that is actual genocide that is
not a one-sided war that is genocide
when that is actually happening Harvard
media these people are are
quiet 198 million interpret the verse
when then the rocks and tree will call
oh Muslim oh servant of God there is a
Jew behind me come and kill him it is of
Jew trees and Muhammad's last
words
calling for the death of Christians we
triy to warn you about this Gerald and I
close to a decade ago not Muhammad what
about salvation and forgiveness how
about
that oh anything now Muhammad what shall
I say of
you how do you feel about the
Jews by the way I'm sorry that you need
a bodyguard I do I think that's 8 years
old I think it's more we made the
references publicly available back then
we make them available now you comment
you consider this genocide
which one is more genocide if we're
going to go super gen is it the Native
American thing or is it is it the Native
American story you've been told
or is it Hamas Hezbollah the Iranian
regime I I I think that one when they
say hey we actually want to exterminate
all Jews period I think that would
qualify and by the way the only reason
we're allowed to discuss this I have no
idea how many times they've had to hit
the YouTube dump button today I'm sorry
uh we can do this because of your
support notice no sponsors toss in the
show today lot with c.com mug Club join
up $89 annually you get this wonderful
hand etched mug it's the only way to get
it you get Nick depalo every day you get
the Hodge twins their weekly show Brian
K you get an additional hour of show
today I guess we went late sorry hope
you guys are okay with another probably
40 minutes today uh Alex Jones on Friday
so much more but it's the only way that
we're able to talk about this hey if we
worked for the New York Times we
wouldn't be able to and by the way if we
worked for a lot of conservative Outlets
we wouldn't have been able to say the
things that we said yesterday and the
funding of Israel yeah and the funding
of wars in the Middle East the more
libertarian approach it's entirely
because of viewers like you mug Club so
we appreciate it if you are watching on
Rumble right now the easiest way to join
is just click that button and it'll be
seamless for you we're going to uh
continue with a story oh gosh this one's
oh boy a writer got 60 days in jail for
calling a journalist a fat lesbian now
just to be clear she is a fat lesbian
YouTube piss
off
[Applause]
what